avant de regarder ce programme du côté
de Manille et les hameaux juste une
information qui concerne s'inspire
l'école la maison de la famille et le
casoar et ouvre aujourd'hui une double
inauguration deux ans de travaux plus de
2 millions d'euros investis et sincérien
peuvent désormais disposer et des
services dédiés à la famille ainsi à la
Maison des familles accueille dans un
même bâtiment planning familial service
d'aide comme Yvelines médiation le CCAS
le service logement et périscolaire le
casoar situé dans les sous-sols du
bâtiment c'est un local dédié à la
culture vous envoyez quelques images les
travaux ont permis plus d'accessibilité
de sécurité de confort les amateurs de
musique qui peuvent bénéficier d'une
salle de répétition avec des instruments
un studio d'enregistrement également une
salle de spectacle les explications avec
Bernard Debin le maire de la commune de
Saint-Cyr l'école qui nous précise le
rôle de la Maison des familles
tout ce qui peut toucher à la famille
avec des gens qui viennent faire des
permanences il y a la Croix Rouge qui
vient pour de l'alphabétisation
un écrivain public pour aider les gens à
rédiger des documents des courriers et
puis
bientôt les assistantes sociales qui
vont pouvoir venir un seul guichet un
seul endroit vous avez par exemple une
personne en difficulté qui vient faire
une demande par exemple de logement mais
là aussi peut-être un problème avec une
donc on peut en frappant la porte d'à
côté elle a tout de suite une assistante
sociale plutôt que de dire aux gens il
faudrait que vous preniez rendez-vous
voilà on va vous donner l'adresse la
tout peut être fait dans une seule
visite
et nous parlons des femmes ce soir dans
cette édition du 7 8 du 26 février après
le rendez-vous réactive les femmes chefs
d'entreprise à Montigny-le-Bretonneux à
Saint-Quentin on s'intéresse à
Magny-les-Hameaux à présent jusqu'au 8
mars femme du monde sur les routes de
l'Europe on va revenir peut-être sur le
choix du thème c'est le carrefour des
civilisations l'Europe une terre de
contraste qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé
justement vers ce territoire là pour
cette manifestation parce que nous nous
sommes promenés un peu dans le monde
depuis six ans
on a fait l'année dernière c'était les
routes de Lorient il y a deux ans
c'était le Japon j'étais venu j'étais
venu vous voir un sujet et puis il y a
eu d'autres d'autres choses comme ça et
nous sommes dit que pourquoi pas
l'Europe
enfin revenir chez nous un petit peu
pour faire découvrir l'Europe aussi aux
populations de Manille qui ne sont pas
forcément européenne d'origine
on a découvert leur
et voilà donc c'était c'était pour ça
qu'on a on a fait ça alors je voulais
préciser que c'est le centre social de
manique municipale qui est porteur du
projet et comment vous avez travaillé
comme les années passées aussi avec les
associations de la commune avec le donc
c'est le centre social qui est porteur
on travaille avec beaucoup de services
il y a le service culturel il y a le
service des sports il y a et puis il y a
énormément de l'association qui se
greffe tous les ans volontiers pour pour
donner des activités des ateliers voilà
alors il y a aussi du il y a de la
culture il y a du sport enfin la culture
il y a des films qui sont diffusés des
ateliers cuisine
irlandaise j'ai un atelier de tapas du
Sud-Ouest
il y a un stage de d'aérobox
d'aerobox je précise alors que nous
avons besoin de faire de la boxe donc
comment ça se passe non c'est un sport
de de mouvement de boxe sans frapper
évidemment et mais c'est pour pour que
les femmes sachent aussi qu'elles
peuvent aussi pourquoi pas faire de la
boxe faire de la et puis un stage aussi
pour
le remise de l'image de soi si vous
voulez pour comment comment oser
s'arranger être belle pourquoi pas etc
il y a beaucoup de femmes vous savez qui
ne n'osent pas s'arranger un petit peu
elles ont peur de plaire elles ont voilà
donc cet atelier relooking justement
nous y avons participé nous y étions
présents nous l'avons suivi on l'appelle
plus relooking c'est image de soi image
de valorisation atelier images de soi
revalorisation regardez
oser être belle voilà le message à
retenir de l'atelier conseil en image
organisé au centre social de
Magny-les-Hameaux dans une ambiance de
salon de thé 14 femmes sont venues
papoter look maquillage et coiffure avec
une spécialiste si on grossit ou si on
mincit ou après une maladie bon bref on
a vraiment du mal à s'habiller parce que
ce corps il change et on adapte jamais
les vêtements donc on va prendre à
décomplexer et surtout à rééquilibrer
avec le vêtement ce corps pour
dissimuler des hanches généreuses éviter
le gilet long dix formes et préférez une
veste courte qui donne du volume en haut
du corps un des précieux conseils
partagés sans tabou donc bien d'écouter
un moment où on expliquait sur sur les
bijoux comment porter les bijoux quel
type de bijoux peuvent aller l'école
aussi je m'en rends compte que mon col
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être pas le col
idéal qui m'appelle mais pas forcément
en valeur donc ça permet aussi de se
rendre compte que parfois on fait des
choses qui sont bien pour s'en look et
parfois des choses qui sont moins bien
celles qui assumaient le plus leur corps
repartent confortés dans leur idée de la
féminité en l'élégance avant le corps
c'est-à-dire qu'on soit ronde de mince
grande ou petite ce qui est important
c'est de se sentir bien et de prendre
soin de soi en fait pour prendre soin
d'elle cette maniequoise a pris une
semaine de congé afin de participer à
toutes les activités proposées par sa
ville dans le cadre de l'événement femme
du monde qui se clôturera le 8 mars lors
de la journée internationale des droits
des femmes
quel premier bilan on peut faire que ce
soit sur cette manifestation ou sur
l'ensemble des rendez-vous qui sont
proposés
énormément de participantes alors
évidemment nous acceptons aussi les
hommes parce que si jamais ils sont
présentes on les rejette absolument pas
c'est vrai que c'est un public
essentiellement féminin mais par exemple
il y a des activités comme il va y avoir
une randonnée un micro-trottoir des
choses comme ça avec une restitution des
réponses du micro-trottoir et d'une
discussion autour de ça sur les droits
de la femme l'évolution des droits de la
femme comment les gens les perçoivent
etc mais il y a énormément
d'inscriptions au fil du temps au fil
des des jours là déjà depuis hier il y a
eu beaucoup d'inscription en plus c'est
pour les adultes mais pour les enfants
aussi parce qu'il y a un atelier à
partir de 4 ans atelier princesse
de nos grands-mères alors évidemment
maintenant il y en a beaucoup moins des
coffres de grand-mère mais quand même
quand même de trouver des des
décorations des choses des tissus des
bouts de tissus des qu'on peut assembler
faire et puis faire un costume et après
il y aura la restitution et ça ça va dur
toute la semaine prochaine oui ce sera
pour débuter les vacances
et ce sera clôturé par le film Maryline
avec Muriel Robin avec un débat la suite
enfin c'était cette femme qui est femme
de ménage et qui a une équipe de dont
les rapports change au fur et à mesure
du film voilà au cours du film programme
complet est à retrouver sur le site de
la ville de Magny-les-Hameaux on
continue à évoquer ce rendez-vous avec
un sujet un peu plus sérieux que les
ateliers principes et princesses on va
écouter l'interview d'Elizabeth Prade où
elle est conseillère en emploi au Centre
d'Information sur les Droits des femmes
et des familles et le centre qui fête
ses 30 ans elle était présente à manie
cette semaine on va l'écouter nous
parler de l'accès aux droits et de
l'aide aussi à la recherche d'emploi
le gros problème il est là c'est que
souvent la loi n'est pas appliquée et
c'est pour ça qu'on va voir des
disparités aussi bien des salaires que
on parle des plateformes du plafond de
verre effectivement pour les jeunes
femmes
diplômés oui c'est une réalité
même chez les ouvriers les femmes vont
pas être payé de la même manière sous
prétexte qu'elles peuvent tomber
enceinte ou qu'elles ont des enfants en
bas âge elles vont être
elles vont pas être traitées de la même
manière ou en tout cas pas par rémunéré
de la même manière que leur conjoint que
leur conjoint ou que leur homologue
homme et ça c'est compliqué il y a de
plus en plus d'entreprises et de grandes
entreprises qui signent des conventions
concernant la parité dans l'entreprise
et sur le bassin de 50 ans il y a enfin
Bouygues si tu es que et d'autres
ils font beaucoup de publicité là-dessus
oui des entreprises prennent conscience
qu'il faut mixer les publics et aller
là-dessus maintenant il faut absolument
que les femmes
osent comme il faut qu'elles osent être
belles et laisser les complexe il faut
aussi qu'elles osent aller vers des
métiers on n'a pas l'habitude de les
voir et là on en revient avec cette
interview à la thématique qu'on abordait
au début de cette émission la question
de l'emploi des femmes chefs
d'entreprise dont on parlait tout à
l'heure le travail qui est mené cette
semaine sur le rendez-vous à
Magny-les-Hameaux vous le menez aussi
tout au long de l'année la destination
des femmes justement de toute façon au
centre social c'est enfin ça va changer
parce qu'on a on est en train de faire
évoluer un peu la structure puisqu'on a
un nouveau projet social financé par la
CAF et donc dans le projet social il y a
l'intergénérationnalité il y a les
jeunes on va s'occuper beaucoup et
forcément de l'emploi puisque il y a un
service emploi au sein de du centre
social voilà donc et tout ça crée du
lien de toute façon le but c'est
maintenir le lien entretenir le lien
social et ça marche quelque soit la
génération quel que soit le sexe
effectivement éviter surtout les
générations et ça c'est très important
juste pour terminer sur ce rendez-vous
du côté de Magny-les-Hameaux votre
rendez-vous coup de cœur c'est un moment
à ne pas manquer sur la manifestation
alors il y a le restitution je crois que
c'est vendredi prochain la restitution
du micro-trottoir justement j'aimerais
beaucoup savoir ce que les gens pensent
de l'évolution des droits des femmes
selon les générations etc qu'est-ce qui
manque qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire encore
et qu'est-ce qui a été fait j'aimerais
savoir ce qui reste dans les têtes Merci
à VOUS femme du monde sur les routes de
l'Europe jusqu'au 8 mars à Manille et
hameaux je vous le disais programme
complet à retrouver sur le site internet
de la ville et puis cet entretien aussi
à revoir en replay sur le site internet
de tvfils 78 à suivre dans le 7 8 de ce
26 février la chronique de
l'environnement et puis une rencontre
aussi tout à l'heure avec Bertrand
Révillon journaliste diacre il nous
présentera conversation spirituelle
recueille de ses échanges avec des
personnalités autour de leur croyances
de Bernard Pivot à Jean d'Ormesson pour
l'instant de nouveau locaux de La
Farandole inaugurée à Coignières à la
farandole c'est un centre de loisirs
réservé aux élèves de primaires et de
maternelle
c'est l'heure du goûter au centre de
loisirs de Coignières un goûter un peu
spécial car ce mercredi on inaugure la
section primaire de la farandole le tout
nouveau bâtiment en bois fait face à la
section maternelle ouverte en 2006 des
locaux de 400 mètres carrés des espaces
de jeux modulables plus spacieux de
grandes fenêtres et des couleurs
chaleureuses alors ce jour-là c'était
jour de fête c'est un moment un petit
peu spécial et partage et en plus ils
ont ils ont la présentation de leur
petit film qui ont fait par rapport à
leur projet théâtre donc ils sont très
impatients de le montrer aux élus et
c'est voilà surexciter là je les trouve
très calme parce que toute l'après-midi
ça a été un peu la surexcitation les
élus présents ont pu découvrir des
cénètes sur les règles de vie du centre
ou encore des chorégraphies
on le met à la poubelle en plus du
théâtre les enfants pourront bientôt
s'initier à l'environnement avec un
jardin potager et un hôtel à insecte le
bâtiment répond d'ailleurs en partie aux
règles HQE une volonté verte de la
mairie qui se félicite des nouvelles
possibilités qu'offre le centre des
facilités des des passerelles plus
facile avec le primaire l'ensemble du
centre le permettant donc je pense
qu'effectivement il y a des projets
ambitieux qui vont se mettre en place
dans les mois qui viennent le fait de
pouvoir aussi faire face à un plus grand
nombre si nécessaire était une condition
intéressante pour
inaugurer et faire ce centre
complètement
60 enfants sont déclarés dans le
primaire mais le bâtiment peut en
accueillir 20 supplémentaires ils ont
quitté l'école Bouvet pour prendre place
dans leur nouveau locaux aux vacances de
Noël et depuis ça s'amuse allez la
journée se termine à la farandole il est
temps pour les parents de venir les
chercher